hey what's up my name is Samuel Leeds
and I'm a property investor today I had
to drive all the way from London to
Liverpool because I lost my passport and
I had to get a fast track and Liverpool
is one of the only places that can do it
here's the thing right I'm just been in
this building I dropped a WhatsApp
message in the academy group and I said
has anyone got any property deals any
really juicy deals maybe no money down
rent to rents nearby where I'm at and I
had a bunch of people responding but the
closest property here's one in this
building right here and there's a guy
called Adam who secured this I think he
was no money down this is a rent to rent
and he's making crazy money like 1 500
from a little tiny apartment and he's
just controlling it he's got a whole
bunch in Liverpool so I'm going to show
you around the building Adam's going to
show us around and we're going to pick
his brain into how he secured it he's
had some challenges with this so you're
going to learn a lot you're going to
enjoy this one let's go
[Music]
what are we doing what's up bro
this is so close I literally walked here
I was in that building right there
literally like City Center location
right here that's just crazy with
parking as well this apartment well
let's all look around for the minute
yeah yeah just had a guest move out this
morning actually they were in for about
10 days in days
first question is if I'm a guest when
they get here yeah how do they get in
there's a shop it's a key Nest it's
called so there's a key Nest about 500
meters away because you don't get
anything outside is it was it
appropriate option yeah okay that's a
really good tip though so if you can't
get a key box outside you've got to be
thinking you got a little shop around
the corner yeah okay so I would go to
the shop get the key yeah you go to the
shop give them the Code so I got my key
I'm here
how do you communicate with your guests
because when someone books and they're
staying how do they know what to
experience like is there a video or an
email explanation so that when they get
here they know this is where I'm going
there's a lift we have like a video
tutorial that we basically show them
okay well this is the shop like we
videoed ourselves going to the shop to
get the keys and then to come to the
thingy they know how to access the
garage which is around the side and then
coming upstairs obviously seeing the
floor and getting access to your
apartment and that's so important
because it just stops getting people
like oh I'm lost where do I go obviously
you're doing this kind of job you expect
it a little bit but this is one of the
most tedious parts of the actual process
of constantly getting the same questions
over and over again so systemizing that
using the channel management using
unlisted YouTube videos and things like
that as well yeah okay so this is the
apartment this is the apartment so how
much rent are you paying for this this
is 1200 pound rent this is a duplex
apartment
foreign
[Music]
this is bedroom number one Madison that
must be a hotel here's a little tip as
well I don't know if you did this if I'm
looking at taking on a service
department in an area I'm going to be
going to the hotel speaking to the
cleaners and I'm like hey how many rooms
are generally fall in this hotel you
know oh I'm just looking around asking
the reception if that hotel's full and
that hotel's full and that hotel's full
if they're all full then you know that
your apartment's gonna be full what due
diligence did you do like market
research yeah so excited we did a lot of
it online so we used like the ad DNA
platform things like that but one of the
key things that we did is actually there
was a lot of construction work going on
so we went to people that were staying
in the malmesan car park and we went on
an early morning one day and we actually
asked the people that was coming out of
the malmes on like what made you pick
here find out a little bit more about
them so we didn't actually go into the
hotel but we were asking the actual
guests why they was there and there were
a lot of Contracting work in Liverpool
at the minute so again if you're like in
an area where there's lots of nice
resorts around and or there's you know
Cadbury World I've got a property right
there Cadbury World it's on Airbnb I've
got it as the pictures yeah you know
because I know that a lot of people so
it's there on one of the pictures so
yeah that's really important you talk
about understanding your client okay you
don't rent this room out on its own you
rent the whole duplex out yeah the whole
apartment gets rented out nightly basis
really the last guest that was in was
actually a relocator they wanted to come
to find a property in Liverpool so they
were coming to move but they wanted just
to stay somewhere whilst they kind of
scooped up the city a little bit and
like looked for the houses and things
like that from that we've had like
contractors barristers for the the
courts around the corner and stuff as
well and just like people that are
coming for like a shopping weekend away
it's another thing we always ask people
for what reason they're coming because
we don't want to annoy the apartment
building itself we don't want like loads
of drunk people coming for like messy
weekends so we make sure we vet the
guests and stuff
bedroom number two this one's ensuite as
well we've got a and oh man you got the
water View and everything so here's a
question for you then Adam there's all
these well-established hotels charging
100 quid 150 quid similar to what you're
charging yeah the question is why would
someone book here instead of there
because this is just like an unknown
it's in an apartment Block it's
advertised by Adam who no one's heard of
yeah
why would they stay here and how do you
market so it's marketed obviously
through like our online travel agency
platforms your Airbnb your booking.com
and things like that we also have a
direct booking website which helped us
build our brand a little bit more and
get things out there but people would
stay here because again it comes to the
market but we Market our fact that the
home from home Comforts that you get
here like we haven't seen it yet but
we'll go in and through the kitchen and
the living space and stuff like that and
you don't get that in a hotel like if I
wanted to come here to Liverpool for a
few days with my kids and my wife yeah
we wouldn't fit in a hotel here me and
my wife have been here kids upstairs
let's have a look at the uh oh yeah
[Music]
you don't get sofas and stuff in hotels
you don't get your kitchen appliances
you're ready to get this in a hotel
you'd be talking
300 quid easily talk to me about the
figures so you're paying the landlord
the owner yeah 1200 you're charging
about 120 to 160 pounds a night yeah
what's your occupancy rate over the last
few months it's been just over 75 which
is good because it's just gone January
February which are like you worst months
of the year yeah so the property itself
is turned over about just over three
thousand pounds in the last couple of
months taking off the bills council tax
all these kind of things like cleaning
fees and stuff as well and then after
that I'm about between 1200 and 1500
pound profit on this property
that's good bro so you're making about
1200 1500 pounds profit a month after
all your expenses yeah how much time are
you spending here and managing it and
stuff the setup of it all it's time
consuming like making sure that you've
got everything like this can furnish
this property and we still spent about
1500 pounds on it to like get your TV
your plants all your kitchen stuff and
everything because it needs to be ready
to live in so setting up time is a
little bit but now I haven't seen this
property in
like since the beginning of the year and
how long is this lease over because this
is a commercial lease right yeah
commercial lease how long is the
agreement with the landlord three years
you put down 1500 quid to get it up and
running plus your rent that was upfront
presumably yeah a bit of down cost but
if you're making 12 1500 pound a month
profit yeah we probably put in the front
end they're about four thousand Pounds
into it and that's for the deposit The
Upfront brand the TV and the video yeah
so again it's like photography and stuff
for the like making sure everything
looks as professional as possible the
actual setup fee for the cleaners to
come in and like they like created a
pack so it's like any cleaner could come
in and just follow the point-by-point
process if you work with a cleaning
company that's just one person it's like
they get ill or something like that and
you're a bit knackered whereas we work
with a company that's like about 10
people I think so they've got a pack so
any one of them cleaners can come in and
just go through the pack right stage the
bed's the way they want they can leave
the nice little print on the kitchen
roll or on the toilet rolls and things
like that and just make sure that
they're all bang on and ready to go but
this is just one of ten I've got you've
got ten now what's the any problems
you've had you mentioned to me a bit a
time ago you had I think it might have
even been this one you had an issue with
the the Freeholder yeah so the the head
lease on this property it's the thing
that you've got to check for all
apartment blocks when the apartment is
leasehold so you don't own the land you
just own the actual apartment itself so
all apartments like this tend to be
leasehold then it tends to be that
there's a there's like some rules and
some of them say I can't do short-term
laps which is annoying but there wasn't
any rules in this one we checked it
beforehand and then we did get a little
bit of back and forth from the actual
Freeholder themselves anyway they
contacted the landlord which contacted
us about it and basically we had to take
it down for a little bit and then we'd
resolved the issue we said look there
was nothing in your rules or anything
like that and then they granted us
permission to do it again and that's
also about doing a good job if you're
doing like parties and stuff in there
you're going to upset the landlords
there's no head lease restriction you're
doing a good job yeah yeah and now
you've got full consent they're happy
that's brilliant
and I love the view so are you gonna get
more in these blocks I would love to get
more but it's again it's just when they
become available really when they do if
the landlord's got multiple you'll be
the first because from the landlord's
perspective is a thing right people
think why would the landlord do this
well he's getting his 1200 pound yeah
he's got a fixed three-year lease yeah
he's got no issues with tenants there is
no tenants if you don't pay the rent
within 21 days you'll be out you don't
have tenants because the guy's staying
here they might be 10 days 20 days
they're guests so there's no tenants in
the equation which from a practical
perspective yeah it's amazing so you've
got a few in this area where is your
closest one from here and can we go look
at it now I've got one that's like five
minutes well I've got three that's like
five minutes that way so there's one
that we've just been doing a little bit
of Maintenance and that stopped and then
there's one other one that's got another
guest coming in tomorrow how much are
you making a month on average not from
your deal source and everything like
just from your your recurring income
from this strategy at the minute about
five okay and then you're also packaging
and selling deals yeah in fact your
package yourself rent to rent deals as
well yeah how much do you make from your
from your deal selling deals selling
turnover about 15 some of them are
coarse deals so other people bring me
the deals
iMac 50 of that so yeah seven and a half
so all in all you're making about 12
Grand yeah yeah and how long have you
been in the business yeah August August
respect my man love this let's go look
at what one or two others and I hope
you're taking good notes and I hope
you're enjoying this smash the like
button give Adam some love let's go
there's one like literally two minutes
up that way that one's pretty new that
one but it's doing good and then we've
got this one coming down here which
we're gonna go to now and then there's
another one over in anfield how does it
do in anfield what's your marketing it's
literally you walk out the door and you
can see the stadium yeah I had one in
anfield and it
wasn't builds and stuff but yeah
the egg is not Posh is it no the areas
the bit that's a bit of a struggle
really but when we could talk about
marketing and stuff the brand that I'm
building around furnished accommodation
uh service department business is
primarily two contractors and that's a
four bedroom house massive space it
works out like really really well how's
the one in Halifax the hurry good
Harrogate that's it yeah yeah Harry gets
sick I believe it's like an untapped
location to be honest I think it's great
like it's really high end it's quite
upper class kind of environment and
there's a load of stuff going on around
it like people do like going for
weekends away again there is demand for
contractors there's the army base that's
right next to its well so there's a lot
of stuff going on around people
traveling for that which we've noticed
again just doing the research in terms
of the area in itself actually another
one that I'm looking at in Harrogate
which I'm hoping to potentially take on
in this this model where I utilize an
investor to take it on as well because
this one then that we're about to go to
I'm looking forward to seeing how you've
structured it with the investor that's
going to be really interesting all right
how many properties are like this that
you take in on average every month now
there's about two a month at the minute
so crazy I've got 10. talk to me about
how you structured this one because it's
quite clever what you've done yeah so
I've found this property and when it
came to setting it up I realized that I
didn't have the capital to actually set
it up so I got an investor to Source it
to I was selling it to them but they
were like I really kind of want to hand
off like approach like do you know any
management companies in the area like oh
I've got one just close by so I can
manage it and then I were like what
about like Furnishing the stadium what
companies did you use what kind of place
did you buy it from I can do that as
well for you if you want so this
structure would just become my business
model now of like sourcing a property
that works for me in my location because
then staging it and Furnishing it and
charging a fee to do that as well right
and then managing it as a service
accommodation property afterwards so
it's not necessarily a JV so we both
don't have the contract together it's
the investors property but you're
managing I'm managing it and taking it
each step so you're getting a sources
fee a setup fee a management fee and
putting in no money so I'm getting paid
to take the properties on shut up
awesome
so I noticed straight away these have
all got key safes outside yeah indicate
that more than one is is a short stay
left yeah first thing I look for when I
go on a viewing especially on apartment
blocks as well is can you see these
because if you can it tends to be a
communication I mean we go through that
digital yeah this is a posh keyboard
normally they look like that one over
there
so this integrates with our management
system basically each time it generates
a new code for each guest how much does
this cost that was 180 quid that 180
quid it was the cheap ones are about 15
pounds yeah this is nice because it
keeps changing the code every time
automatically yeah boom boom there we go
it's good as well because I've seen
something something recently about
people getting broken into all like key
box has been smashed yeah every time
that that opens or it's opened we get a
report oh good so there's that pings to
our phone so even when the cleaners are
going in the maintenance going in you
you know yeah and what time they're
going out yeah exactly that's good
[Music]
huge what is this is this a residential
block or is it commercial or what no
there's a lot of residential around here
but I think that well this is called
tobacco Wharf it was a massive tobacco
Factory so how much rent does the
landlord get for this it gets 1200
similar to the other ones so is that
your
like numbers
the one because of the parking space
when we come in we've got like it's got
secure parking as well so we aim for
contractors and things how many bedrooms
there's two bedrooms but the beautiful
thing about it is obviously we staged
them really well we use zip and Link
beds so like this can be two singles and
then the other bedroom also can be two
singles this has got a zip in the middle
I can feel the zip yeah and like links
up there yeah you could get two two in
the other room four seven bed five five
contractors charge more there's more
people yeah yeah so you transfer it and
then if there's more people you charge
per head per night yeah and this is our
model of like what we do when it comes
to actually marketing the properties and
stuff and actually reaching out to
businesses like look the flat rate of
you staying here is x amount what would
it be here what's it would be the flat
rate here is about 120 and then it'd be
40 pound per person on time so if you've
got five people a group of Builders
you're talking you're talking 280 and
nine and if you're playing the loud 1200
you get Builders coming here for a month
you know times up by 30 eight and a half
Grand and obviously every month ain't
gonna be like yeah yeah how much profit
does this make and how much do you get
for managing it so I get 15 of what the
profit turns out of the so this property
makes again similar to the one that said
numbers are similar so it makes about
three grand okay so you're making about
450 quid and then the investor after the
rent has come off and the cleaning and
things like that they're making between
five to seven hundred depending on the
market so they're making more money than
you but you've got no risk yeah well
obviously the property loses so this is
where we have a relationship with our
investors so if the property loses money
again it's part of the it's an
investment at the end of the day
sometimes you will lose money but unless
the investor hits a certain threshold we
will take a management fee that gives
them the Extra Protection that okay if
you're making x amount or more so
normally it's around 300 if you're
making 300 pound a more then we'll start
charging nothing okay that's nice
another thing I want to mention is the
importance because the first thing I'd
be checking if I was looking at this
property and I was looking at second arm
I'll be saying number one what's my 4G
doing
yeah it's got five bars good number two
what's the Wi-Fi speed because these are
things that can really hurt your
business so you've got Wi-Fi in here and
everything is it pretty quick yeah the
Wi-Fi is good and who would generally
stay in here than Adam what type of
guests are you getting so it has been a
bit of a mix since we've started with
this one but it's primarily again this
is a lot more contractor whereas the
other place is a lot more either like
professionals and kind of like weekend
away kind of thing man imagine that
you're moving how and you have to sell
your house to buy another house normally
you're gonna need a little stop Gap yeah
exactly because the chances of your
house selling and the new house
completing on the same day is very rare
we're gonna stay are you gonna stay at a
hotel and pay 150 pounds a night or you
can stay here where you've got your own
kitchen the kids can play it's much
better so for relocaters contractors
business professionals and tourist
potentially if I'll come with a couple
of friends I'd rather stay here than in
a hotel you got a bit of shared
space office space do a bit of work from
here that's really key as well because
when it actually comes to listing it on
certain platforms and stuff like that a
little amenities that you can add Leica
working space and things like that we
had a group of builders in anfield
because well I know you've got
properties we rented a property you're
not going to believe the store you might
have heard it already actually we rented
a property for 450. two bed house I'm
going back about three years now we
rented it out to contractors one month
this is our best month ever we went four
grand and the house was only worth like
60 Grand my wife said to me we could
literally afford a deposit to buy the
house within a few months yeah yeah for
rent people say rent to rent is illegal
what would you say if they say is this
not subletting and illegal what would
you say it's all about like the
contracts that you use rather than it
being like an AST normal tenancy
agreement you need to use the the
commercial lease agreement the company
let agreements and things like that that
allow you to use the property as a
business to do what you want to do as
your your business for us obviously
letting it out on a shorter term basis
but this landlord for this property has
given me another one in Manchester
because he likes the model so much he
likes the fact that he's not a hassle we
take care of a lot of the Interior
maintenance terms of like painting and
whatnot as long as it's not like boiler
or electrics and that kind of stuff I
love that model so much you just give me
one of his in Manchester which is right
next at City Center I love it man well
we're off to Manchester now anyway today
you guys want to join us you want to
meet Adam because he's usually there I
want to come and spend some time
learning how to do this I'll tell you
something there's a Revolution going on
right now in the UK it's equally the
playing field between the rich and the
poor normal average everyday people are
beginning to be able to get into
property via this method you didn't have
any problems last year now you've got 10
properties that you can draw I know how
does it feel to be a successful
full-time property entrepreneur it's
ridiculous like the road map that I've
been given for this and then by the end
of the year my goal is to have 20 on
this model and then have five that I own
and it's like now I'm constantly
building relationships with investors
and things like that it's like it's
crazy so there's a revolution if you
want
rent Revolution and learn the exact road
map of how to do this we're going to
leave a link in the description come
down one pound come meet me meet Adam
let's go I'll see you there book on